anybody that's been in business ever
knows that word of mouth is probably the
most important part of building your
brand whether you're a product like Red
Bull you don't think all the club goers
the in-crowd built that brand or crystal
or Grey Goose or if you're landscaper or
dentist or a lawyer
you think those ads that you buy in the
Yellow Pages mean anything mm-hmm word
of mother effing mouth now let's talk
about word of mouth in 2008 it's a lot
more powerful it's on steroids it's
Roger Clemens in it it's Barry Bonds in
it it is on absolute steroids in this
day and age with social products like
pounce and Twitter and all Jayco and
dodge ball I don't I just wanted to go
there Facebook and MySpace with
bulletins or whatever you use whether
it's Bebo or you know Orkut depending if
you're in Brazil right with the way
we're going now and with the SDK stuff
you don't think there's gonna be an
amazing billion dollar company that's an
application through texting eight
trillion people in two seconds
Pech twitter is that now right um so the
fact that matter is where this world is
going on June 16 2008 um people need to
recognize companies need to recognize
that word of mouth is absolutely more
explosive more powerful than ever let's
talk about the biggest socialite in 1998
a decade ago heck let's go to 2001 the
biggest socialite you knew could only do
so much damage with her or his word of
mouth what 30 60 80 and email is fine
but very very spammy but in a world
where you connect to people and you have
the option if you want to follow them or
not word-of-mouth now isn't a greater
impact to every business and brand than
it's ever been in my opinion and it's
going to continue that way and so that's
what's really important now for people
to understand how powerful word of mouth
is how important word of mouth is and
how people's reach with their word of
mouth has expanded to levels we've never
seen before or could comprehend where
people have 40 50 thousand followers
when do you think what excuse me what do
you think is going to happen when we
life non-internet brands get involved
with things like Twitter when Lindsay
Lohan when Tom Cruise when Oprah Winfrey
has a billion followers on a Twitter
like product I mean what do you think is
gonna happen the impact the speed
anybody using these new technologies
knows what I'm talking about now doctor
listen 99% of the world doesn't know
about this yet what happens in the next
24 36 48 months when the rest of the
world catches up and starts using these
social tools to get their word-of-mouth
into a greater space the whole marketing
and branding of brands is gonna go
upside down flip and newspaper ads and
billboards and radio spots are gonna
seem very unsexy and brands where are
you coca-cola Gillette Procter and
Gamble which is Gillette I mean where
are you where are you leveraging these
brands now why are you not testing the
orders and a much bigger way when
word-of-mouth now is so powerful when no
longer is it just a celebrity pitching
your product anymore when three or four
common folk with a lot of following on
the Internet can do that kind of damage
where are you
word-of-mouth 2.0 is the future